the jogan experience when I understood
my value in that Penitentiary at 17 when
I got certified at
17 5 to
15 subtract five out of 15 in state
prison that leades you to back time to
walk off called
perole they had a boxing gym there in
all of the Pennsylvania prisons which is
plus
had boxing in a Penitentiary that was
part of baseball flag
football handball on the
wall that
spark that flame came back from little
short amateur career I had that's how I
built my reputation up in my
neighborhood I always fight fight
fighting in the streets fighting in
school how old were you when you first
boxed as an amateur like when did you
first walk 9 years old my uncle took me
to the gym my mother's brother cuz my
father had a brother that boxed too and
they all was my weight well I was all
their weight when I started
middleweight my uncle's on both sides of
the tree mother and father uh box that
middleweight in the 60s 7s early 70s so
it's in my DNA right can't help myself
is who I who I am and who I became but I
got back to it when I went to the
penitentary so when you were an amateur
did you were you taking it seriously or
were you were no I wasn't taking it
seriously you weren't fully committed I
was eating everything everybody else was
eating at that age in in the
neighborhood and what was there I mean I
remember fighting and getting a trophy
about this big it's always the same
stance right plastic trophy but you know
to me that was like a gold medal you
know they got the trophy shown everybody
in your neighborhood and the elementary
school I was
at and then you know they take you to uh
you know I want to get no free
commercials but they take you to this
this you know this still around you know
to get a hamburger and french fries and
you probably know you know to take you
there we happy that was it right uh
amateur program but it was like the pal
right I I don't know if they have it
here in Texas the P called Police
Athletic lead it's big over there in the
east coast so the PO lead was uh
structured to get
young black urban men that's on the
corner or young boys right to go to Pal
anybody can go there but m mostly was in
our neighborhood they would you know
come to the gym and you know you can
sign up for amateur boxing you could be
Olympic gold medal you can do this and
do that but I I had you know family
members I was in my DNA once I was taken
to the gym by Arty McLoud we call him
Arty but it was author McLoud called him
moose my mother's brother middleweight
badass look him up Ry McLoud uh the
streets um took his career obviously
based on what
Lifestyle the Streets of Philadelphia
the blue collar Town worker uh
Philadelphia can make you or break you
when it comes to um making it out of
there right not only Sports any
Entertainer any success that you might
have on your back in that in the
community again Phil there love there
but a lot of of us don't make it out
even though the talent was better than
mine just strong the Trap of the streets
the the the the Trap of the the streets
but the also um what you're used to
doing and what you're used to thinking
listen until I travel through boxing
tell you how much boxing did for
me to travel around the world multiple
times meet multiple people from every
class of life that I that I I believe
you know I'm pretty sure it's people I
haven't
met but from here to there to to
to uh status of power or influen
influencers I said
man the world ain't just nor Philly the
world the world is not just Raymond
Rosen
projects so I start standing now like
even sitting there watching at that
time how the fork in the spoon and a
butter knife is on one side of the
table and I'm looking at F this guy is
taking a act and pting on the floor I
think he's putting on his his lap I mean
this might sounds ignor ignorant but you
got to understand from that mindset of
what I'm saying not understand my
experience cuz some
haven't but I start paying
attention that was the key just like in
the boxing business I start paying
attention and then once I
got to the point where I had a voice
means I had to do something in
boxing nobody cares if you consider
nobody uh 10 in one because I lost my
first
fight Atlantic City to Clinton
Mitchell I was out for n months
out of penitentiary I want to get right
back in the ring before I grab a kilo of
cocaine like everybody was selling in
the 80s and
90s that was the plan I had a choice to
do one or the
other right eight everybody listen
anybody on West Coast and East Coast
know the 80 and the 90 era right the 80
and 90 era in urban
city was
get down and lay down 84 I was
booked 84 my brother got
killed Shirley May Hopkins lost two sons
in
84 talking about
trauma that was a key key
key
push and
experience that I had to do something to
make her
proud to make her proud once I get out
still got years to do how many years did
you wind up doing five five to 15
subtract five out of 15 the way the
Pennsylvania parole board works if you
get
out on your minimum is five you can do
the 15 you get into a stabbing you get
writeups you do something in
there that can be a crime
too the five is the minimum the 15th is
the
max so I had to walk a straight line
amongst
chaos no
confusion everybody 90% of people there
they know why they
there what they
say they know why they
there
that
moment after that first
year of establishing
myself filling out the
environment of who you deal with who you
stay away from who to
snitch
what guard what Co is good what Co is
not most of the CEOs live in the same
neighborhood you grew up at it was the
brother of your uncle
friend who never had a felony so he got
fill application he got a job now he's a
CEO I know your dad okay
thanks hey SE can I you know get an
extra commissary what
goe so you're not really protected by
nobody because anybody can sell you out
or do a
favor but what I'm trying to understand
is just physically I understand that you
didn't party I understand that you very
disciplined but how are you physically
able to compete at that level deep into
your 40s because of again lifestyle
everybody else falls apart because
everybody else is doing what everybody
else been doing
what were you doing different physically
physically I
was always even to the day I pay
attention to what I put in my body as
who I am not what I actually look like
and I understood that
most people that I seen in my time in
boxing Floyd's disciplined to same way
don't drink don't smoke and be sitting
right there in the club and everybody
doing everything else you heard that
before all over you got those type
people like that but genetics plays a my
grandmother lived in '99 but then again
do I really take all
the eggs and put in that basket because
my father and mother died before 60
so I would say the lifestyle I would say
uh the mindset or the teachings or both
uh hit not get hit um you know read
books a lot do something to exercise
your brain take care of your physical
body the
penitentiary the penitentiary taught me
more going there once I got there to
understand what I wanted to do I wasn't
just lifting weights in a weight yard
and be swo up around a bunch of men for
five years I went and understood that
hey after a year went by they got a
boxing program I wanted to get off the
block to go to another block and the
Guard Co said where you going W 4145
hey I'm I'm going to the gym but I'm
trying to go on a block to hang out
before count to go back on my block if I
don't do it if I don't get old before
can I get it right up so I was forced to
go down the gym and seeing people
sparring and I said I want to be a part
of that and I got my
ass beaten
lesson and I didn't like it and I never
been afraid to go in the gym
again
30 years
later I said I would never go in a ring
or any situation ill repaired or
unrepaired I always go in there
prepared that lesson that I said to
you then and I say to you
now being in that institution having
that experience going in in that gym for
the first first time and say after a
year went
by and only by
accident that I went down that gym
because I was hited to another block as
I said earlier and then get down that
gym cuz boxing was in the penitentiaries
in that era we had boxing there attached
to the
aaou which is the same thing they have
outside he to bring young fighters in
there to fight us the amateurs have
shows for the inmates you buy a ticket
at the commentary you go to the fights
that
Friday and inmates watch you root for
you I didn't like how I felt I wasn't
prepared they didn't beat me because I
wasn't
better I got beat
because I didn't
run I got beat because of the
ego I got beat because as they say the
word hater that I go down there you know
want get in there with him yeah come on
I used to box when I was in the streets
you know that's that's that's the common
talk I should do this when I was in the
street
okay but those same old-head trainers
that double life or one life sentence or
two life
sentence they spoke about me on behind
of Glory Brian Gumble look it up is out
there they spoke about me When I visit
that same prison in my early
professional career guess what doing
what sparring for my Atlantic City
preliminary fights when I was building
my record to get to where I became a
champion I became the usba champion
which is a sister of the
ibf world championship
belt I left that
Institution anyone would have ran much
far as as far as they could they' have
ran so far from that place and never
want to see it
again but
after six to seven months of coming from
a first professional loss with Clinton
Mitchell in Atlantic City look it
up I took off 89 and 90 the streets was
grabbing
me I still had seven and a half years
parole through the math nine
years I rebooted my first fight I
believe was in 91 90 and
91 but that crucial moment that year and
a half if you look up my record you'll
see Clinton Mitchell 89 inactive 80 uh
89 inactive 90 inactive 91
what was happening these 16
months I made a
decision meeting a old guy named Buie
fiser gu rest his
soul he won a champ we won a
championships he should be in the Hall
of Fame because of me I'm already in
there I'm the only fighter he ever had
very few trainers SC in Hall of Fame
with one Hall of Famer or fighter
fighter gets but the training might not
and I'm not saying it's bad or good I'm
just saying that's how it
goes